Nico: From exclusive
items to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the
differences between Starbucks
in Italy and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
Our hot drinks in Italy
come in four sizes:
short, tall, grande, and venti.
Our hot drinks come in five sizes,
short, tall, grande, venti, and
the coffee traveler.
Two of these, like grande
and venti, are Italian words.
Venti means 20 in Italian,
and grande just means big.
Let's measure them out to see.
The name translates to 20, but it is not.
In the US, iced coffees
come in four sizes,
tall, grande, venti, and trenta.
Trenta is not available as an option
for their espresso drinks,
but you can get it in stuff like cold brew
or their iced teas.
Our iced coffees come in three sizes,
a tall, grande, and venti.
Let's measure the venti to see
if it actually is 20 ounces.
Eighteen ounces.
So, again, not a true venti.
It's more like a diciotto,
which is 18.
We're also going to weigh
some popular food items from Starbucks.
Let's start with the butter croissant.
So, it's a pretty big difference
to how much Italy's weighs.
It's a lot smaller.
Another popular bakery item
is the blueberry muffin.
Let's see what it weighs.
Here's everything that you'll
find at Starbucks in Italy
that you won't find in the US.
Here's everything that you'll
find at a Starbucks in the US
that you won't find in Italy.
We know that Starbucks is popular
because of its customization options.
So because of that, we're
only going to look at
the official menus in the US and Italy.
These are the exclusive hot drinks
that you can find at
Starbucks here in Italy,
starting from this tiny cup.
This one is barley coffee.
In Italian we call it caffè d'orzo.
And it's basically an
alternative to espresso
for those people that
cannot really drink coffee.
It has the look of coffee.
I'm not a fan of this.
I think, you know, because I
can drink normal coffee, so,
but if I were not able to,
I think I'll just force myself to like it
just for the pleasure of
still having my espresso.
And then we have a vanilla latte.
It does smell just like a
cappuccino, really, but.
Obviously it's past 11 or so,
so it's past breakfast time anyway,
so cappuccinos are a no-no drink for me.
I'm not so much into drinking milk
after a certain time of the day.
And then we have latte macchiato.
And then we have this one.
This one is a salted
maple and caramel latte.
It just smells like sugar.
It's nice. Yeah, it does taste
like fake, artificial syrup.
And then we've got some teas.
We got Teavana English
breakfast, jasmine pearl,
high-biscus, or ih-biscus, as we say here,
and chamomile.
And you may also be able
to find the Moroccan,
which in Italian just translates
into literally Marocchino.
It's like a tiny cappuccino, in a way.
There's a bit of coffee and
a bit of milk, obviously,
with its own proper ratio.
And it's named weirdly
after a Moroccan leather
that has the same color
that this coffee has.
It's a brown-ish, light brown leather.
That's actually very popular here
in the northern region
in Milan, where we are.
So, here are the hot exclusive
beverages we bought today.
This is the caramel apple spice juice.
The apple crisp oat milk macchiato.
We have a blond vanilla latte,
and this is a royal English breakfast tea.
We also have these exclusive hot drinks.
I feel like I have to try
this caramel apple spice juice
because it looks nothing like juice.
So I'm interested.
I think it's just hot apple cider.
It doesn't taste bad, actually.
That tastes pretty good.
I'm going to try the royal
English breakfast tea
in honor of Harry.
It's not my favorite.
But my preference is iced tea,
not hot tea, so maybe that's why.
And I also like them a lot sweeter.
We have lots of exclusive
cold drinks here in Italy.
We didn't get everything,
but here's what we've got,
starting from a cookies
and cream Frappuccino.
I'm quite surprised this
is exclusive to Italy
because I always associate
cookies and cream with the US.
It has held its shape in the delivery.
To me, this is a bit of a foreign idea
because we just have the
boring chocolate flavor.
Yeah, like chocolate cookies. Nice.
It's like a childhood memory.
Here are all the Fraps that we got.
So, we have the chai cream.
This is the mocha cookie Frap.
This is the apple crisp
Frap, the pumpkin spice Frap,
and the white mocha cream Frap.
I feel very compelled to
try this mocha cookie Frap
because it just looks like a milkshake.
It looks like dessert.
There's literally cookie crumbles in it.
Yeah, it tastes like cold chocolate milk,
specifically Nestlé syrup chocolate milk.
An apple crisp Frappuccino
sounds kind of special to me,
so I really want to taste it.
Kind of tastes like a candle.
I don't like that. Not at all.
But I tried it.
The pumpkin spice Frap
and the apple crisp Frap
are seasonal items,
so you're not going to be
able to find them year-round.
And then we have iced
cold foam cappuccino.
We don't really have a lot of foam here.
It also looks quite dark for a cappuccino,
but maybe that's just
because the foam is gone,
but I don't know. They
keep putting hearts here,
but I'm not really tempted to try this.
And then we have an iced
salted maple and caramel latte.
Does smell a lot like sugar, actually.
Not even like maple. It
actually just smells like sugar.
And you can see the sugar at the top.
I did live in Canada for one year.
Let's see if it does
actually taste like maple.
I don't know if I can advocate
for Canadians out there,
but for what it's worth,
I'm going to try it.
There's no maple in there, definitely no.
It's like sugar.
Not even caramel. Just a lot of sugar.
I feel like a Canadian
would never order this.
But that will be another
episode of "Food Wars."
And then we have iced chai tea oat latte.
Again, quite surprised that
this is exclusive to Italy,
because we're not so big on chai.
I don't know. For some
reason I really like chai
as, like, the tea version,
but I've never really
quite liked it with milk.
So, we have cold brews,
but we also have nitro cold brews,
which are a little bit frothier
and thicker than the regular cold brew.
This is the pumpkin cream cold brew.
This is the cinnamon caramel
cream nitro cold brew.
And here we have the vanilla
sweet cream nitro cold brew.
I already know that I love
the pumpkin cream cold brew.
I kind of want to try
this cinnamon caramel one.
No, not for me.
It's a little weirdly sweet
for something that doesn't
have any milk in it,
I don't think.
Let me try this one.
This one's really good.
I really like the vanilla
sweet cream cold brew.
That just tastes like a
really good foamy coffee.
We then have this one,
the very berry hibiscus Refresher.
And then we have a matcha frappé.
Again, I don't know how
this is specific to Italy
because I think the whole matcha craze
has kind of maybe spared us, in a way.
But there's no other place
where you will find any matcha flavoring,
because I think our
green thing is pistachio.
Like, we just don't have space
for two green things to compete.
Let's give it a try.
I've never actually had
it in a Frappuccino.
Yeah, tastes like matcha.
Just very artificial matcha.
We have a bunch of other iced
coffees that you can get.
Here they all are.
And today we actually
bought the iced flat white.
I've had this before, and
I think I really like it,
but I just want to take a sip again.
Still good, still delicious.
It's a little milky,
but it's really tasty.
We also have several iced teas.
Here we have the pumpkin cream
chai, the matcha lemonade,
a peach green tea, the
London fog iced latte,
an iced passion tea, the frozen
strawberry acai lemonade,
and the frozen mango
dragon fruit lemonade.
Starbucks sells these
Evolution Fresh juices.
This one is orange, apple,
mango, pineapple, and acerola.
That sounds really good.
I've never had matcha
and lemonade together,
so let's taste it.
That's actually not bad.
I thought I was going to hate it.
It's actually pretty good.
Let's try the London fog tea latte.
No! So candle-y!
I feel like I'm going to keep saying that.
Why does everything taste
a little weird today?
I do want to try one of
these frozen Refreshers.
Let's see what this
strawberry acai tastes like.
It's really good. It tastes
like strawberry lemonade.
It's not frozen anymore, but it's tasty.
We then have a bunch of smoothies.
We have this Innocent blue juice,
and the names are actually funny
because they are a play on words here.
This one is called Fa-Blu-Loso.
Then we have a pink juice from Innocent.
This one has another play on words,
it's Rosa A Iosa.
And if you're Italian watching this,
yes, I'm from the south,
because you can tell by the
way we pronounce our O's.
We then have these tiny ones.
This juice is mango,
passion fruit, and apple,
and another one with
strawberry and banana.
Yeah, they look very nice and natural.
We have other cold drinks.
This one is a chinotto,
and they're all from this brand Tomarchio.
I've actually never heard of it,
but it looks like a fancy chinotto to me.
So, chinotto is an Italian
drink made with bergamot.
We normally just have
it from San Pellegrino,
which is a more commercial
brand. Does tastes good.
It's a bit like the Italian
version of Coca-Cola.
My parents' generation, they
were having these, not Coke.
We then have a red orange.
We have sparkling soda
from the same brand,
and we have lemonade,
which looks very nice.
And then we picked up also this.
It's just cold infused water.
In Italian it's called Infuso A Freddo.
And actually we've got more.
Here are the rest of the cold drinks.
Here is the US Only customizable
drink that we created.
This is a caffè vanilla coffee Frap
with half-and-half.
The cup is lined with caramel sauce.
It's got brown sugar syrup, mocha sauce,
and cinnamon dolce sprinkles.
And also I think some cookie crumbles.
There are some mysterious crumbles on top
that I have no idea where they came from
because I didn't ask for
them, but it looks fun.
This is going to give
me the worst tummy ache,
I already know.
That is the sweetest drink
I think I've ever tasted in my life.
It's too much. Absolutely too much.
It is really fun that Starbucks
lets you customize anything,
pretty much anything,
because this would never
have been made otherwise.
There is a lot of food at
Starbucks here in Italy.
Let's start from the savory options.
We've got your dear salmon bagel.
I don't know, does that
have cream cheese in it?
No, it does look like just salmon
and some herbs.
Some sad salad.
Yeah, this is also cooked salmon.
And aren't you big on, like,
smoked salmon over there?
I don't know. Nico, you are in New York.
What do you think from a
New Yorker point of view?
Does that look like a good bagel?
No, it does not.
But maybe it tastes better than it looks.
Now, we have some toasts.
We have ham and cheese.
Looks like an honest toast.
And then we've got the same version,
just with three cheeses.
I'll be curious to know
which cheeses they are,
because they just say three cheeses.
And then we've got
baked focaccia with ham.
Well, OK, first of all,
this is not focaccia.
I mean, I don't know what this is.
It looks great, actually.
Looks very nice and fluffy.
But this is not focaccia,
because it just doesn't have the shape
and it's too fluffy.
It just looks like bread to me.
Yeah, it just looks quite nice, actually.
Like a normal sandwich you would find.
It's quite refreshing
because I don't know
when this is going out,
but, like, the amount of burgers
and things filled with weird sauces
I had to try for this
show is just unbelievable.
And Starbucks, I don't know,
but, like, it looks like
you really made it in Italy.
You're, like, serving actual Italian food.
So thank you.
And here we have some of our
exclusive breakfast items.
This is the Impossible sandwich;
the bacon and Gruyère egg bites;
the bacon sausage egg wrap;
the bacon, Gouda, and egg sandwich;
and here's the berry trio parfait.
Let's take a bite of
the Impossible sandwich.
I've had this before, and I
feel like I mostly like it.
It's just a little bit weird
if you let it sit for too long.
I feel like for a not-real sausage patty,
this actually tastes pretty good.
I've always thought that the egg bites
were some sort of genius move,
even though Starbucks
definitely didn't invent them.
My favorite are the egg white bites.
These don't look edible
anymore, but I'll take a bite.
That's really good, actually.
I think it's just because
I got a mouthful of bacon,
but it tastes really good.
And then we have a bunch of sandwiches.
Here we call sandwiches tramezzini,
but it's just kind of translation.
We have this one with salmon and avocado.
Looks nice, even though the
options outside of the box
look very, like, look delicious.
So I wouldn't go for the boxed one.
We have this one with porchetta,
which is roasted pork from
Rome and the Roman region.
Very, very good.
And, yeah, if you're ever around there,
they also do a lot of nice
festivals, so check it out.
This one has porchetta and mushrooms,
and the last one is this one
with zucchini and eggplants.
We also got salads.
We have chicken and cheese,
what looks like grated Parmesan,
and then we got tuna and feta
with croutons and olives again.
This is all you need for a salad.
The only Caesar we know
here is Julius Caesar.
I know that's bad, but actually it's true.
It's just very, very
cliché, but it's true.
We don't like Caesar salad.
And then we've got this
one, it's called pincho,
with cured ham, artichoke
sauce, and mozzarella.
OK, interesting shape. It looks funny.
I don't really know what a pincho is.
It may be something from
another Italian region.
I'm not so familiar with it actually.
To be honest, this
artichoke is a bit of a joke
because there is not a lot of it.
Let's try it out and see.
That artichoke actually
tastes quite natural,
so very nice.
Yeah, it's not flavoring.
Yeah, I like this one.
We then have some stuffed croissants
because here we're not French,
so we're not scared of
putting things in croissants,
like our friends across the border.
So this, they're quite similar.
This one has cured ham and
scamorza, it looks like.
A little salad thing.
I honestly, I don't really like it.
Doesn't taste like much,
and it just ruins everything visually.
Next croissant we have, I
think it's the same cheese
just with cooked ham instead.
In Italy we actually do eat
a lot of savory croissants.
Sorry, French people.
We usually eat them as
tiny bites in an aperitif.
They serve them. They're
really, really this size.
They're very tiny.
We also have this one,
which is supposed to be a focaccia
with a plant-based schnitzel.
I mean, honestly, this is not focaccia.
I mean, quite clearly there's
been some mistake in the menu
because it's just a sandwich,
and I don't know, why
do plant-based things
always have very sad buns like this?
Why don't you use this one?
This looks much nicer.
This is just very sad and plain.
We do have some snacks as well.
We have some mixed fruits and nuts,
we have roasted and salted mixed nuts,
and then we have cheese snacks.
OK, this looks like it's a thing,
because McDonald's also
has those tiny Parmesans,
those tiny Parmesan snacks,
and Starbucks seems to be following suit
and just giving you some cheese snacks.
It just says it's a semi-hard cheese.
And it's only made with
three ingredients. Nice.
You know, milk, salt, and rennet.
OK, no, I'm a bit disappointed.
I was expecting actual cheese,
like tiny bits of cheese.
This is like, it's like a chip.
Yeah, they're cheesy. They're
not too bad, actually.
Moving on to our more lunchy options.
This is the grilled cheese on sourdough.
The tomato mozzarella
sandwich on focaccia.
They also offer a ham
and Swiss on a baguette
and a Turkey provolone pesto on ciabatta
that we did not get.
I want to take a bite
of this grilled cheese.
The bread actually looks pretty good.
There's not going to be a cheese pull.
It's going to crack in half if I do that.
It's literally so solid
from sitting here all day.
[crew laughing]
OK, wait, it looks like
there's no cheese even in this.
That's so weird.
It must be a lighter cheese.
I've had way better grilled cheese,
but this bread's actually pretty tasty.
This sandwich seems
inspired by Italian flavors,
so I'm very shocked that
it's not on the Italian menu.
That is one sad-looking sandwich.
I'm going to take a bite from the middle.
Don't be mad. It's just
that all the filling
has moved to the center of the bread.
It's not bad. It's not great,
but it's not a bad sandwich.
It mostly tastes like pesto.
We also have a variety of protein boxes.
Here we have the PB&J protein box.
This used to be my lunch every single day
when I was in college.
Starbucks in Italy has
a lot of bakery options.
This I'm very excited about
because I think we do actually
associate Starbucks with
a breakfast café, in a way.
Starting from a maple and pecan braid.
Then we have a cinnamon swirl.
Yeah, it looks nice and fluffy.
And then we've got the saddest,
saddest-looking croissant ever.
This is the vegan one.
It's just a very unpleasant brown.
Is this what the lack of butter makes?
Like, just something very brown?
It doesn't feel that great, and inside,
it just actually ...
it cuts a little bit like a bread,
in a way.
Right, bread's vegan, yeah.
So here's some bread in
the shape of a croissant.
And then we've got another croissant.
This one is multigrain and honey.
And then we've got a plain one.
Very good lamination, actually, Starbucks.
Look, there's a lot, a lot of layers.
Actually, Starbucks
called these croissants
"French croissants" in Italian as well.
And they actually do look quite different
compared to the Italian
croissants that I'm used to.
Italian croissants,
they're not made of layers
of dough and butter.
Let's see.
A plain one, I will have it
only if it's laminated this way.
I think the Italian one is
just really meant to be filled,
so I'm curious to see how the
others actually look and feel,
just because they are
still the French ones,
but they are filled.
So, we've got this one
here with apricot jam.
Let's check it out.
Yeah, lots of jam.
Looks quite nice.
And then we have the
green thing here in Italy
that is not matcha.
It's pistachio.
Tastes like a nutty spread.
Quite a nice spread.
There's not a lot of it, though.
And final one, we've got the custard.
This also looks quite nice.
Just want to see how much
custard there is in here.
There's a lot. It's a bit eggy as well,
which is what I would
look for in a custard.
Not too lemony, just a hint.
And a bit of vanilla.
And apparently you can also
get a hazelnut croissant,
but we were not able to get it.
And then we have a double-chocolate cookie
and a hazelnut doughnut.
Yeah, we're starting to
enter foreign territory here.
Maybe a bit sad compared
to what's coming after,
which are these mini doughnuts.
Quite cute and colorful.
And then we have some brownies.
We have a caramel crumble brownie,
and then we have a
triple-chocolate brownie.
I actually quite like brownies.
It's one of those sort
of foreign cakes that
I'm kind of very used to,
and I don't mind having it.
Let's see if we do it well here in Italy.
This is like the ones I'm
used to that I've had.
And then we have this one.
It's a raspberry and coconut loaf cake.
It does look a bit like
a typical Italian cake.
I had no idea that this type of cakes
were called loaf cakes,
but seems quite accurate.
Not quite convinced about
the stuff at the top.
It just doesn't seem necessary.
I would've put it inside
just to flavor the dough
rather than just put it at the top.
And then we have a strawberry cheesecake.
Then you may also be
able to find apple pie;
apricot-filled rings;
custard and raisin swirl;
then a vanilla and chocolate muffin
that's also available in triple chocolate,
brownie, and orange;
mini chocolate muffins;
carrot cake, that can also be
red velvet and chocolate cake;
and a milk chocolate gold coin.
The US also has a lot of baked goods.
We have a couple of the
iconic Starbucks cake pops.
I want to take a bite of
this cookies and cream one.
That's so good.
This is the blueberry scone,
the everything bagel,
the petite vanilla scone, the coffee cake,
even though it looks
like someone sat on it.
It looks a little smooshed,
but it's very good.
The incredible, incomparable lemon loaf.
It's delicious.
The glazed doughnut.
I did say that Italy's
bagel didn't look that good,
not that ours looks any better,
but I just want to taste
the everything bagel
to see what the flavor is giving.
It's, like, mediocre.
It's not that good on flavor,
and it's not a great texture.
I would only reach for a
Starbucks bagel if I was, like,
going on a flight or something
and this was just my only option.
I don't think that I
would ever purchase it
with a million other good
bagel options around me.
So, the pumpkin loaf
and the pumpkin cream cheese
muffin are seasonal exclusives
along with the baked apple croissant,
which was not available today.
I feel like people are
buying them like crazy.
They're really good.
And if you want the little snacks,
there are also these options.
We've got yogurt with wildflower honey
and yogurt with berries and jam.
Then we've got some fruits.
You can also get pineapple,
and then we've got just a fruit salad.
And finally we've got this
thing, the cookie straw.
So, is this how you're
supposed to have it?
This feels like something
a child would have.
It's like I'm alone at
home and I'm, like, 12.
I'm having a very calorific
drink with a weird straw.
Yeah, weird.
I actually don't mind the straw per se,
but just the idea seems so ridiculous.
We also got a few iconic
Starbucks checkout snacks.
So, this is the marshmallow dream bar,
we have the madeleines,
and we also have the
vanilla almond biscotti.
I see these at every
single Starbucks I go to,
and I'm always tempted to buy one.
I kind of want to try these madeleines.
I don't think I've ever
had a madeleine before.
That's pretty good!
It kind of tastes like
a cakey sugar cookie.
I don't know if it's
supposed to taste like that,
but it does taste like that.
You may also know Starbucks
for the Starbucks Reserve roasteries
that are very much present in the US.
You can also find them in other countries,
and actually there's one
here in Italy too in Milan
that opened in 2018.
And the roasteries are famous for having
different types of coffee
that have the rarest coffee
that you can find at Starbucks.
They offer experiences at these roasteries
where they demonstrate different
ways to make the coffee
through blending, brewing, and infusions,
and they also have wine, beers, cocktails,
some of which include coffee.
They have a lot of food options too.
Each roastery is a little
different in its architecture,
so it's really interesting
just to have a look around.
Unfortunately we were not able
to visit the roastery in this trip,
but we actually went in 2018,
so we're going to play
some footage of our visit.
I was there.
We took a visit to one of the roasteries
here in New York City.
It was really cool to see
how they make these different drinks,
and everything in there is so fancy
compared to a regular Starbucks.
These are the drinks exclusive
to the New York roastery
that we wanted to try.
Let's start with the
hazelnut bianco latte.
I love hazelnut, so.
It's really good.
It's really, really, really good!
I feel like it tastes better
than any other Starbucks coffee I've had.
Let's try the
whiskey-barrel-aged cold brew.
This is intriguing to me.
I hate whiskey,
but there's no real whiskey in this.
OK, wait, it tastes like
there is whiskey in it,
but there isn't!
I made sure to say alcohol-free.
I think from what I'm understanding is
that they might age this
in the whiskey barrels
once the whiskey is
removed from those barrels,
but it still tastes very strong.
It's spirit-free, but
the spirits are lurking.
You can still taste it.
This was actually invented in Italy
and then, yeah, launched again,
recreated at the roastery.
This is the oleato caffè latte,
and oleato just literally means oiled,
and it's just a caffè latte
with a shot of olive oil.
Apparently this is the CEO of Starbucks
that traveled to Italy, to Sicily,
and just saw some people having
shots of olive oil in coffee
and thought it would be a good idea
to roll this out internationally.
And for some reason thought that
all Italians were actually doing it.
I don't know, it's the
first time I hear it.
Like, I would be quite happy
to have a shot of olive oil
for just energy,
but I don't know if I
would like it in my coffee.
That seems like a bit too much.
It's like, "Oh, what are two things
Italians are associated with?
Olive oil and coffee.
Let's just put them all
together and make it a drink."
It's green!
And obviously the oil is
floating on the coffee.
Well, so the idea is that
they should emulsify,
but it's been sitting here for a bit
because we've been doing all the filming,
so perhaps that's why they separated.
It just smells like coffee.
Let's try it out.
I don't taste much the
olive oil, which is OK.
It leaves you a different
feeling on the lips,
like the same feeling that you get
when you bite into a very oily thing.
This is the moment that I've
been dreading this entire day.
The oleato caffè lattes.
These are basically lattes
with a bunch of olive oil in them.
I don't know whose idea this was.
It doesn't sound like a good idea to me,
but let's see which one is
better, iced or not iced.
It's not bad.
I can definitely taste
that there's oil in this,
but it's not aggressively
oily in my mouth,
which is what I was really dreading.
It's really not terrible.
I think it's the oat milk that's helping
cover up some of what's happening.
This looks terrible.
The iced latte has completely separated,
so the top is just a layer of olive oil,
which means I'm going to get a mouthful
of olive oil upon first sip.
It just tastes like a
mouthful of olive oil.
Let me mix it with a straw
and see if that helps.
To be clear, this didn't look like this
when they first gave it to us.
It's just been sitting around for a while.
It tastes better but still
mostly tastes like olive oil.
I think if I had to get an oleato again,
I would only get it hot,
just because it covers up
all the olive oil flavor,
which kind of defeats the
purpose of getting one of these.
But they're not terrible.
It's quite hard actually for me to think
that Starbucks is actually
competing with the cafés
that you can find here,
just because the offer
is very, very different.
Like, it's the only place
where you can find drinks
this size, this elaborate,
and with this much cream and milk
and syrups and all this stuff.
I would say in general Starbucks
is definitely huge here.
You can find them everywhere.
I feel like you're either a Dunkin' person
or you're a Starbucks person.
And it's very common for
a chain like Starbucks
to be somebody's everyday coffee shop.
I will say if you live in a major city
with a lot of other options,
a lot of different coffee shops,
you might not head to
Starbucks all the time,
but it is one of the more
popular coffee options
in places like suburbs.
It's hard to say that it's popular
because it is not really
present everywhere.
Obviously it is in Milan,
Rome, and the big cities,
but you won't find it in a village.
What we do, I'm from a
medium-sized town in Italy,
but in the evening I'll
go out to a small town.
You know, during the day I'll go out
for a day trip in a small town.
I won't live there, but
I will hang around there.
That's where you don't find the chains,
and I think that is what
still makes Starbucks
perceived as something a bit foreign
because you still don't
see it in these tiny towns
and you still see the local café.
It's just in general the idea of chains
doesn't really resonate well.
In terms of the actual
coffees, like the long coffees,
I don't know actually if
they get lots of orders
from Italians.
I think you either just, I
would either go personally
just for a simple espresso
or for the elaborate things
because they are a bit
like an ice cream to me.
Treat yourself, but also,
like, if I see you drinking
that cookie crumble mocha
Frap at 9 in the morning,
I'm gonna slap it out of your hand.
Grow up, please!
Just the culture of, like,
the big drink to take away,
to drink on the go, drink in your car,
that's just not how
things work around here.
People really love the
Starbucks seasonal menus.
I think every year when fall
or Christmastime rolls around,
everyone gets super excited
to see what new stuff is on the menu,
what old stuff is coming back.
I mean, yeah, speaking of the food,
I think they've done a very good job
sort of adapting to the Italian flavors.
The drinks are a little bit different.
There are some things,
like cookies and cream,
that are just not Italian.
We all know that Starbucks
is a big American chain,
and I think they obviously
want to keep a part of that
because Italians are
curious about it as well.
Unfortunately, Starbucks
does not list ingredients
on its website.
We did try to get in contact,
but we're still waiting for a reply.
The US, however, does provide
all of the ingredients
for their full menu.
We thought it would be interesting
to see what's in the oleato range,
since both US and Italy
have this available.
The oleato caffè latte with
oat milk contains oat milk,
which is just water and oats, canola oil,
dipotassium phosphate, calcium carbonate,
tricalcium phosphate, sea
salt, dicalcium phosphate,
riboflavin, vitamin A,
vitamin D2, vitamin B12,
brewed espresso, which
is just water and coffee,
and extra-virgin olive oil.
The exciting thing about
this drink is the addition
of extra-virgin olive oil,
which is mostly associated
with a Mediterranean diet.
It does ramp up the calories
compared to a normal latte,
which with 2% milk is 190 calories.
But there's been a lot of
research surrounding the benefits
of extra-virgin olive oil,
particularly around preventing diseases
and decreasing cholesterol.
Plus the oleato latte has
been fortified with vitamins,
so sounds pretty good to me,
even though I'd never order this again.
In the US, a venti caramel
Frappuccino is $6.75,
or 6 euro and 37 cents.
Keep in mind, that's a New York price.
The prices might vary slightly
depending on what state you're in.
In Italy, a caramel Frappuccino
is 5 euros 70 cents.
That translates to roughly $6.19,
so it actually works out
cheaper here in Italy.
In the US, a venti cappuccino is $6.25,
or 5 euro and 90 cents.
In Italy, a venti
cappuccino is 3 euros 40.
In dollars, that translates into $3.69.
To be honest, they're
kind of fair judging by
how big the things are.
Coffee's always quite
cheap actually, in Italy.
It's usually around 1 euro.
Lately has gone up a little bit,
but, like, if you pay 1.50,
it's already very expensive.
Again, like, I think
this goes into idea of
these drinks are ice
creams, they're not coffees,
because paying 3.50, like, 5, it's a lot,
a lot of money, and
that's just not a coffee,
because a coffee is supposed
to be quick and cheap.